i mean i i don't i think what we're
trying to do and correct me if i'm wrong
you know more about this than i do
which is we we think school is one size
fits all
and it's not because different kids have
different challenges
in different areas of different
challenges in different situations of
different challenges what's the school
that put washing machines in their
schools because some of the kids were
you know some of the kids were weren't
coming to school because they were
embarrassed because their clothes were
dirty
they put washing machines on the school
that's genius to me
and i think that we can't apply this
one-size-fits-all because
at the end of the day the teachers know
more than anybody else than any
politician or any administrator
the people on the ground who touched and
are with the kids every single day
know how to solve the problems like you
actually know the answers
for all of these challenges and i think
we need to empower teachers
we need to give authority to teachers
right what we
the way we do it is we want we ask the
teachers to give us the information up
high so that we can have all the
authority
but the answer is no you don't push
information up you push authority down
and i think we empower teachers to teach
the way they think is the right way to
teach
their children in this situation i think
a lot of that just goes away i think a
lot of those become symptoms
you